and two points for the winner and the
blitz uh or um in the tie breaks one
point for the loser overall and here we
go here we go it's a kingsport opening
from anish giri no more english opening
and it's the sicilian instead
this is very standard stuff um this is
the opening repertoire that carlson was
relying upon in the 2018 world
championship against caruana so lots of
trades early on
now black's queen coming out putting
some pressure on white tonight in the
middle of the board
now okay white coming up with a
temporary peace sacrifice magnus raising
his eyebrows um the white bishop there
is attacked so if black's knight was
captured white's light squared bishop
would have dropped off and ishgiri he
must have hit magnus carson with this
opening surprise the world champion is
slightly frowning he's confused black is
a piece up but he can't preserve his
piece black's extra knight in the middle
of the board will drop next if it moves
then the black queen would fall prey to
white's dark squad bishop so that's a
pin and quite an annoying one for magnus
to face
and this act this line has actually been
played before in 2000 between daniel
kampura and
an internet i think grand master hatan
from mongolia i think yeah so um
very strong players okay and in that
particular game black responded with
supporting the knight with a pawn
okay so black's e pawn could push
forward and defend the knight in the
center that won't preserve the night
long term but it does cling on one more
move to that knight so maybe you can
take advantage of that move what is
magnus doing with his mouse he hasn't
clicked on any squares he hasn't clicked
on any pieces yet he's about to give up
his queen is that right oh my god magnus
carlsen has just given up his queen what
um he's gonna get three pieces in return
but look at this the black knight i said
it was pinned it cannot move it stepped
back capturing a bishop and then white
bishop took a queen right now it's a
crazy imbalance white has a queen black
has a knight and two bishops in return
so actually three pieces they add up to
nine a queen worth nine it is roughly
balanced but when a queen is on the
board it's all about cane safety and
black's king is a clear target in the
middle later on yeah and i have to say
one thing as well it's all
about how those three pieces can
coordinate if they cannot coordinate in
a good way don't ever sacrifice your
queen of
exactly we should mention as well white
cannot take black's knight right now on
that left side with a pawn because then
black's rook in the corner would come
down and take white's rook so there's
another pin on this a-line
black his knight will survive but magnus
carlsen
i've played him before many times at
blitz he if you give him an artistic
choice he'll go for it especially in the
blitz games but it's extremely risky
from the world champion he's really
gambling at this early stage
like ivanka says it's all about
coordination peace coordination but
right now black is a mile away an age
away from coordinating his pieces the
first move that i would consider is this
move that uh anish has just played and
uh enticed the knight to step backwards
and then start moving forward
and aneesh is uh
real he's reading my mind this is what i
want to do and that we saw magnus he
almost pre-moved retreating his knight
because he is also reading uh anisha's
mind your mind ivanka he's expecting
these moves and magnus is about to move
his central knight in front of the black
king out of the way he's clicked on that
piece which way is he going to go with
that knight though
um yeah he's danced around too much too
long already with the black knights it's
really scary for the world champion the
black bishops they are the problem
pieces they are yet to enter the battle
okay
and uh anish geary driving the knight
backwards
attacking it and
the knight has a big problem it has to
move to the edge of the board
this is uh and then again what's it
doing on the edge of the board it can
get locked out of the game and suddenly
it will be a queen against two minor
pieces and that's not sufficient yeah
and that's why magnus pushes a pawn on
this right side firstly he's trying to
break down the integrity of white's pawn
structure those fire advanced white
pawns but he's also trying to find an
escape route for that black knight
trapped on the right on the edge
just in case as your vancouver mentions
it gets trapped so he's trying to open
up his black rook as well i think he's
committed now magnus carlsen the black
king is too far away from castling it
needs to stay in the center it needs to
hide in plain sight and after a trade of
pawns black's rook has opened up look at
the evaluation bar yet
uh yet to settle down yet to make up its
mind the reason i don't like this at all
from any giri is because black is now
maybe got a target black is going to try
and attack the white king look at this
he's pushed the pawn forward daring
anish giri to play on passant which has
just happened capturing the pawn as if
it just moved one uh one square
so you can sometimes
prevent your opponent from bypassing
your own pawn but
magnus now has opened up his light squad
bishop which which was previously asleep
and now look at this developing his rook
across the board horizontally that's
rare that's right unique
but uh i do think that white can copy as
well so he can get inspired by black's
last move and also move his rook on the
same line two squares and try to use the
third row and uh anish goes for a
different option where he just locks out
this black rook and magnus
wow he is playing aggressive chess he
pushes his pawn forward attacking the
knight driving it backwards and saying
to
saying to anish hey
every capture that you make is going to
suit my pieces but look at this ivanka
because look at white's pawns right now
he's thrown everything forward all of
white's pawns are on the fourth rank
there's also one on the sixth rank he's
not caring at all about pawns neither
side about pieces of pawns they're not
even counting i think anymore who's
ahead of material right now that white
pawn is attacking black's rook on the
edge of the board that pawn can actually
just be taken by a black knight but then
white would gain time attacking the
black pieces and forcing the black
pieces backwards so magnus carson is he
he's given up his queen already is he
gonna ignore his rook as well what's he
gonna move his rook is he gonna take a
pawn so many choices for the world
champion this position is just crazy i
think even in the two players minds they
are not sure who has the advantage i'm
definitely not sure the evaluation bar
is definitely not sure this one is one
of the wildest chess games i've seen
probably ever but definitely throughout
the tour yeah and i can tell you top
engine choice is knight take capture the
pawn second is for black just to ignore
the rook and just capture the knight yep
okay he takes the pawn so he goes for
the uh recommended move and now after
white gives up a pawn with the check
black recaptures and now white's knight
has jumped in magnus is under check we
see on his screen the king is
highlighted that just shows its check
but he's getting ready to click his dark
square bishop and take that white knight
and
it looks like it's happened the black
bishop took a night and anish had
pre-moved to recapture with the white
queen that happened instantly and now
the black knight retreating it's still
two knights and the bishop for the white
queen so roughly material balance but
look at this white is trying to get to
the black king trying to open up lines
trying to find a path through
so far black's knight bishop they're
controlling squares there's no check and
if there's no check maybe black is safe
and maybe black is okay and if there's
no check
and no threat of checkmate or anything
then probably it means that black can go
on the offensive as well so anish
pushing forward upon trying to lock down
the lines
okay the black's king can start running
or black can even take a pawn on the
side of the board with the rook on that
left flank
suddenly
okay magnus retreats his knight just
acting as a defensive piece now i'm
slightly surprised because that knight
was preventing white's remaining rook
from getting to the center but magnus
he's confident he's going to survive
knights are a king's best friend and
there's two of them defending the black
king
and uh magnus is just saying hey those
three pieces will defend the black king
and the rooks they're going to start
targeting those weak pawns on the left
and the right
those two black rooks they're developing
not in the way we normally see in chess
normally we see the king castle and then
the rooks come to the center those rooks
are developing up and down the board and
actually i just did a quick count black
is one point up if we talk about pawns
pieces black is a pawn up
so
after all of that
kind of tactical melee
it's uh looking good for magnus carson
and anish he lifts his rook up the board
what's the plan maybe a defensive
maneuver maybe he wants to bring that
rook across and eliminate one of black's
rooks but maybe he'll also maybe he also
wants to just step his rook
to this
one square and then maybe threaten the
sacrifice or something anything to get
at the black king he could have done
that on the last turn i think that's
true not his idea anymore ivanka i think
he's just purely on the defensive
anushkeri um but magnus carson he's
going to move one of his rooks i'm not
sure which one but he's going to move
one of his rooks oh no he moves his king
there we go just looking on the screen
he dragged his king to the side there
away to safety and now there's danger on
the board because the black rook is
threatening to attack the queen and
that's why anish gives a check which is
promptly intercepted by the knight but
look at the black king safe
as the proverbial houses yeah so anish
there he's about to capture a pawn he's
pausing he's changing his mind look at
the thought process from anish giri he's
indecisive he's not sure which direction
to go for with that queen if it can't
break through to the black king then
what to do is he going to step back and
take a pawn no he's changed his mind
he's going to bring his rook up the
board
is he going to challenge black's rook at
the top there he is will we see a rook
trade now this is how difficult the
position is even that these top players
in blitz they're not able to trust their
instincts it's all about calculation
and the rooks are off
and uh now the queen will capture
no the queen cannot capture the pawn at
all
no because of course
black will also go and capture the pawn
that is up for grabs and suddenly
black's rook is black's rook is amazing
the knight that is sitting next to the
king is an aggressive piece so uh the
white queen is forced into a defensive
role and
the problem as well is that the queen
and the rook are forced to defend pawns
and okay wow i was about to say anish
giri he's banking on the fact that
magnus carlsen's pieces the knights and
bishop are tied down defending the king
but magnus gives up a pawn
he's definitely not materialistic he
gives up a pawn in order to activate the
black bishop and a niche there gesturing
looking frustrated leaning back
suddenly the black pieces are coming to
life black's rook and bishop are teaming
up against the same pawn white's rook is
a bit stuck
no targets white's queen
yeah that's why a queen is actually
worth the same as three pieces but the
problem is there's three of them and if
they coordinate if they defend each
other just the fact there are more
pieces to attack with can be decisive so
okay all the pawns disappearing on that
left half what a game you're right kaya
black's rook is now about to come across
maybe deliver a check that can take
white central pawn with his knight
and the three pieces untouchable
the three musketeers yeah totally and
the rook is just
its sole
job on the board is just to gobble up
the pawns so a niche
dropping to nearly under a minute left
on this clock both players now around
the minute mark and the clock situation
uh is not in either player's favor but
it's definitely magnus carson's favor on
the board and it's going to be difficult
when you're facing a queen there's
always traps there's always tricks
that's why he steps back look at those
black pieces literally every single
piece defends another piece and uh okay
anish geary meanwhile he's got fewer
pieces to play with so he uses the white
king
i mean this game i'm going to go back
and study it for hours i think just so
much to think about okay the black
bishop now attacking white's rook
breaking a bit of coordination with the
pieces but nope the bishop is replaced
on its previous square and that's right
and that black rook it's going to
relocate itself
two squares further down the board it's
gonna go and protect the white king yep
protecting the bishop and at the same
time
like david said
heading at the white king yep it's gonna
swing across the board that black rook
and again supreme blitz strategy this is
why magnus carson is the best blitz
player in the world always defending his
pieces he doesn't care that he has no
queen he's just defending everything
look at this bishop steps back he still
created this nice little cozy home for
the black king
i mean that's the safest king i've ever
seen even though it's being stared at by
white's queen even though it's being
stared at by white's rook
that king is super safe it's incredibly
safe and also
magnus just limiting all risk whatsoever
he just dropped his bishop back to
protect
his pawn okay so check and and anish
just cannot do a thing you know now
another pawn drops off the board yeah
black's ruckus gobbled up all the pawns
and black now is two points up two clear
pawns all black needs to do is start
going for the white king i feel um once
the black pieces coordinate it's gonna
be checkmate maybe we'll see checkmate
coming the black pawn can push forward
to attack the white queen okay magnus
just steps back with his rook deadly
threat now of checking the white king
from the front with the black brook also
for black's knight to jump in towards
the white king
it's game over i think that white king
is doomed there's gonna be no way to
save this game magnus just needs the
finishing touches now the black knight
can come into the attack i was going to
say that black knight but magnus says
okay it's fine i can just push my pawn
and
again every single one of magnus's
pieces
are protected it's as if the black king
has got all his clothes on the white
king look at it it's naked it has no
protectors no defenders around it it's
feeling really vulnerable right now
and uh the white queen has found a safe
square but not for long black's rook can
give a check here in two different ways
two different directions he steps back
just again protecting everything over
protecting everything just in case
and uh
well magnus is just really perfecting
the art of i was going to say suffering
making his opponent suffer and look at
this black pawn this lone black pawn the
pieces are all perfectly placed for
black so use your pawns now
to create the threats and white just
trying to get to the black king but
nothing
anisha can do here black's king is too
safe
and okay one threat on the board white's
queen is trying to take that black rook
because there was a pin it was
undefended so magnus again defends
everything he attacked he defends his
blackrook and he attacks white's rook
gaining time
and now the knights finally start to
mobilize they've protected each other
for so long but they will finish off
this game
and
here it comes the pawn is closing in on
its destination
and another check
let's just look how
this is just an exercise in dominance
now it's a queen on the board and that's
it game over magnus carlsen wins the
first tiebreak game and what a game it
was impressive